the diver ceo live my live show my live
reincarnation of this podcast is coming
on tour and it's coming to a city near
you there's a link in the description
below put your email address in and i
will email you when tickets go on sale
can't wait to see
[Music]
everything that people said well you're
lucky to work with dr varna
and i can say that wasn't luck it was
strategy
what's that imposter voice saying is
going to be found out good question i
suppose do you have insecurities yeah of
course i do has that ever had a impact
on you
i never believed my own hype it's very
easy once you see yourself in articles
and winning awards and everyone's
telling you how amazing you are but i i
suppose i never really did
i didn't fit in particularly well and
i've seen the extremities of mental
health me myself going to dark periods
where nothing would nothing to fight
nothing would cheer you up if you
haven't got a thick skin you shouldn't
be in this game
david gandy at one point he was one of
the highest paid male models in the
entire world
a beautiful beautiful man and so hearing
that and seeing how beautiful he is
would understandably make you assume a
lot of things about him
but what you're going to hear today is
that those things are wrong and that you
should never judge a book by its cover
how is it possible
that someone that looks like david gandy
can describe themselves as having
imposter syndrome being low in
confidence
and waiting to be found out
he's now become an entrepreneur he's
focused on launching his brand new brand
david gandy well where and he's taking
on a completely different industry
it's crazy because when you open
people's diaries
you never know what you'll find and what
i found in david's today
was truly fascinating
unexpected
vulnerable and extremely
surprisingly relatable
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett
and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
there's a lot of
very beautiful people in the world right
um but they don't manage to achieve what
you've achieved across multiple
disciplines whether it's within your
modeling career which is incredibly
competitive
space to play and one with shrouded with
huge amounts of uncertainty or whether
it's now in business with what you're
doing with your brands there and your
investments
so my question is what is it about you
in your sort of self-diagnosis that has
made
you
rise to the top in those
pursuits
that's a
good question and also where did it come
from
the easiest one to say is probably the
modeling one to to start off with and
that was
um
i
questioned why
men weren't in the same position as the
female supermodels and you had
the equivalent of the the male super
models at the time and you always have
that but they were never to the you know
to that level
um
of fame of you know sort of financial
rewards of
uh as as the female supermodels and i
questioned that that was all and thought
is there a possibility is there almost i
suppose a gap in the market
the first five years no one actually
realizes that i really didn't do that
much for the first five or six years it
was you know
of course we didn't struggle and it was
a lot of
um
you know sort of catalog work earning
really good money wasn't what i wanted
to do but i got to work
with you know like sir chrissy turns and
naomi campbell and those people and i
literally just observed them and asked
them questions
and
sort of got the answers i wanted and i
all realized that it was a business for
them
they had great teams they had great
agencies they had prs and pas it was run
as a business and then you had the guys
you know who were the top of the fashion
that at the time it wasn't a business
for them it was
a lovely way of making a living and they
were felt very fortunate to be there
some of the time not even admitting that
they were
models they were in advertising or
marketing as a lot of people used to say
and i just used the female platform and
i went to head of my agency tandy
anderson
and said
i i don't want to do this commercial
work anymore
it doesn't satisfy me it's not when she
said what do you want to do i said if
i'm going to do this i want to be the
best at it and she said right literally
from tomorrow i've said this a million
times you have to stop all that
commercial work because we have to you
have to be perceived then in a total
different light to
to get to where you want to be so every
bit of that working i said wearing very
good money i
just quit everything we just we said no
to all the campaign no to all the
catalogues and she said to me like in a
position you've got that's what most
models are dreaming of earning what not
dreaming of but that's you know they see
you yours is an enviable position i said
tan it's just not what i want to do i'm
not happy doing it so to me i had
nothing to lose because i would have
carried on so we then started building
up this other perception of me within
the fashion industry not the catalog
model not the commercial model but
editorial a bit more sort of fashion
based and that's when we
instigated a meeting with dolce gabbana
and that's how i did their campaign the
campaign led to
light blue and
light blue was a to me a tick in the box
for them to achieve what i wanted to
achieve
and it was
phenomenal success and it still is
but that was that was what i needed that
was the platform pretty much from there
and then we could put the team together
to say
where do you want to be in three years
what and where's the next three years
after that where do you want to achieve
and i'm a big believer in having goals
not always having to achieve them things
change but i'm big believing having
goals so you know
roughly where you're where you want to
end up at something and then game is a i
always say sorry
life is like a game of chess and you're
moving pieces to get to that checkmate
to where you want to be and often it
diverts and you have to have different
tactics but you you have to have that
ambition to know
the exact point to where you want to be
of course when you get there and
being a
maybe an entrepreneur or typical person
i am then i'm on to the next thing
you're not particularly satisfied and
you know i've achieved that so
what's the next achievement where do you
go from there what role do you think
luck has played
as you view your journey in hindsight
what role and you know everyone you know
especially very successful people will
always have a kind of different
relationship with luck what role do you
think luck has played in
your
journey and however you would define
luck
it annoys me if someone says or you're
very lucky
and i feel like i have to go on this
statement go hang on let me just tell
you about
you haven't seen the hard work that's
gone in there and i realize that it sort
of gets you nowhere um so
listen i
was fortunate to be born like i am six
foot two in the frame i have with
the way i look and people perceive that
as
they the way they do and it's
you can make money from that
hugely fortunate
but as you said before there are a lot
of good looking people there are a lot
of beautiful people i've admitted myself
i go into my agency there are
25 better looking guys on that board
there are 50 better models i've just
cast 10 of them for my brand they're my
they're better models than me they're
better spokespeople than me i was
fortunate to be in that position but
then you
and say you make your own like you maybe
you do
so every
sort of
everything that people said well you're
lucky to work with dolce gabbana and i
can say well let me tell you how this
the story of how we went to meet dolce
gabbana how we instigated that yeah that
wasn't luck yeah it was strategy
and
it was
not my i think at the time everyone's
going you are armani you are raffler in
your mind you're afraid it was tandy
anderson who said you are dolce gabbana
you're adult shigebang i don't listen to
anyone else you are deutsche it was her
genius
that said and then sort of instigated
this meeting with them
and then
through that and working with tandem
working with select everything we've
achieved
is strategy you know it's gone out it's
like think what do you want to achieve
what do you want to
what's your goal
and it just it doesn't just happen yes
there's certain opportunities that come
around that people approach you
but we approach a lot of people with
ideas and we approach from people would
love to do this yeah you know m s
it was
us who wanted
to do that collaboration
and i wanted to do it with one of the
biggest
british institutions everyone knows and
everyone has a great thing i wanted to
do with m s we had lots of different
brands approach us
we didn't do that we wanted to do it
with m s
and that again looked at we didn't start
off by just doing a collaboration and
you know a huge deal it was i had to
model for two years with them prove that
i could still prove that i could work
with m s
then we talk about collaboration then we
would move on and
you know then they trusted me it didn't
it's not a finger click you know it's
yeah it's it's it's because the way that
look um those moments the amazing
collaboration that amazing email that
comes out of nowhere in hindsight
because it appears to have come out of
nowhere um it always appears in
hindsight like look and i've got my own
story you know examples from my story
where when i was 18 19 years old i went
on linkedin and typed an investor the
first person that came up i emailed him
he invested in my company
people think you know they say you got
lucky right and i'm like well you know
again it's what to what you said about
the story well look at the email it was
sent at 3am and i shot on stage i'm like
and i then removed the timestamp and i'm
like i was up at 3am
thinking about emailing people so for me
action and what you describe there is
like that smart strategic work is just
increasing probability
that you know you might get what people
call luck and um
in that moment with dolce and kabana and
when when you form that partnership with
them how pivotal was that for you
and the trajectory of your career
in like real terms
light blue is the reason i'm here and i
you know the famous commercial
but again you could look back to that
when i came into modeling
the circle of the fashion world at that
stage of what was perceived as
fashionable was the small androgynous
skinny guy
now i'm
over six foot two i was quite skinny
when i came in but i built up and i just
got bigger and everyone else said
you need to get smaller you need to fit
in you need to you're too big you're
getting too big
but that's where i was happiest i wasn't
doing it for reading you i was always
playing sport i want to continue i
couldn't play sporting while so i was in
the gym and it was you know to have a
good physique and be healthy was the way
i was
happiest in my head in my well-being so
that's what i did and in a way i just
looked at the models and tyson becquers
and titan baloo and paul scoffer and all
these different people that were you
know the levi's guys
the famous levi's ads that we used to
used to look at and the raffler ring
guys i was like
they're all
big muscular classically handsome guys
and they were the biggest in the
industry so i just thought this has got
to come around at one point so when it
actually came around to that creative
for light blue
of course
there was a smaller pop because everyone
had followed each other yeah yeah yeah
and then there was me and we'd just done
the campaign with the auction gabbana
and then we went to and do light blue
but that the day it came out um it just
changed everything i mean literally
changed everything i hate when people
say that but it was went from that
campaign going out in the afternoon
phone not stopping
and i think i went to new york and
my agencies called up and just said
we've got telegraph the times the mirror
they all want to speak to they all want
to have an interview with you
and we didn't have pr's at that point
you know this was i was like okay
how does this work
um
very green about it all but exciting you
know so that that's that change
um so you're talking about lifestyle how
did your lifestyle change and i want to
know about like
how people treated you and friends and
you know romantic potential partners
when that that blows up for you the
phone doesn't stop ringing how does your
world shift from a like a very personal
perspective
friends have never changed
great
and we're still you know on all on
whatsapp groups and see each other i
don't see them as much they all live
closer together and
that's a shame really but it's just
never changed i get the absolute
roasting
roasting all the time i'm just an easy
target
yeah so you can just google my name on
so many pictures that get putting online
so and that's it you know it keeps you
and i love that no one takes themselves
too seriously and i think hopefully
that's what i didn't do too much as i
always said to people if models ever
come up to me now so what made you
different or how did what did you learn
i said i never believed my own hype it's
very easy once you see yourself in
articles and winning awards and
everyone's telling you how amazing you
are to to believe that but i i suppose i
never really did
do you have imposter syndrome yes yeah
yeah of course absolutely and what does
that mean in practical terms in your
mind and your thoughts
you're always waiting to be found out
i think there's the end of the day
you're always waiting for you know you
sort of go
okay all right come on if you've had a
really good inning
you've been 15 years in yeah you're
still thinking well 20 20 years later
we've had a good angst you know i'm
still thinking that today to be found up
you do that by putting yourself at risk
of something it's like
i suppose there's there is the risk and
reward so
everything i do there has to be a slight
risk
otherwise it's not sort of worth
i suppose me doing it so there's always
got to be that risk of failure
in many ways and i don't mind failure
i've learned more from failure than i
have from success to be honest and
that
risk element of
you know
vanity fair asking me to write an
article i mean i'm not a writer
to do that is scary but i won't have
anyone write it for me i have to do it
we're going back to the integrity thing
i have to do it
that goes for sort of the fashion game
to collaborating with brands to
investing
you know as you know it's you know it's
a risk there's an element of risk i take
into i suppose everything and i suppose
it makes life exciting what do you think
when you say be found out what's going
to be found out
what's that imposter voice saying is
going to be found out good question i
suppose
have you bitten off too much then you
can chew but no one can be as
as uh harsh a critic to me as i am
myself
i will beat myself up in something fail
as i will beat myself up if i don't do
the best job
um
so no one can affect me like that by
actually saying anything because i'm my
worst critic
so yeah that's a good point of what
someone you know what that voice is
going to say to me just a whisper of
doubt i guess
that may be
well the way that i typically think
about imposter syndrome or at least i've
seen it in my business and there's a
couple of like top level execs in my
business that talk about imposter
syndrome a lot and it sounds like um
yeah exactly what you described there
like biting off more than you can chew
and
are you really capable and experienced
enough to be at this level doing this
thing do you really have the skills yeah
there's other people that are smarter
and better and that have you know you
know won more awards or more you know
experienced something like that
there's also the side that and it's not
about money it's about success there's a
lot of people that actually don't
particularly want other people to do
well
and
most people
they will try to bring you down in many
ways and put doubts in your mind you
know it's like the sort of the
backhanded commentizer as i always sort
of call it it's it's hard for someone
and i
i've learned you know sort of that from
other people's comments and what they've
said to me and i'd make sure i never
ever do that and i always just encourage
people and if i can help i will help
them and that's probably where my
investments have come from in many ways
is i have had this opportunity and i
haven't borrowed a penny in my life to
get to where i was
you know i when i first went to new york
modeling i used to go around and
couldn't afford
to eating nice places so every time i'd
go on like castings i was walking around
all day and going to shoot i would then
go past a uh like a diner and they would
have a special deal on so it'd be like a
burger fry and something else for 5.95
and i'd write it down go i've got to
remember to come back here because it's
5.95 plus taxes like i suppose i can
have a beer and it might be ten dollars
that's where i used to have to think
because i just didn't didn't have
anything then
i've always wanted to then i think i'd
never really had any help but i would
like to help people talking about
helping them helping people and then
other people tearing people down with
female models i think we can all quite
easily believe how nasty comments would
affect them but there's something in in
i think the public perception or within
society where we think ah if you slag
off a male model if you criticize them
say nasty things about them well they'll
be fine if you go on twitter for example
it's totally okay just uh people will
tweet at pierce morgan all day saying
but the people would never do that to
well they would but it would be much it
would be considered much differently if
they were saying that to a woman i
believe that to be true so i guess my
ultimate question here ultimately is
like
have
strangers criticizing saying nasty
things on the internet about you how you
look or whatever has that
ever had a impact on you
in this business anyway if you haven't
got a thick skin
you shouldn't be in this game you've got
to have a thick skin and it's
what i understood and i've
probably only actually understood this
from having to cast myself for people to
represent my brand is that
you're not being horrible to someone
someone doesn't fit
what you have perceived in your head and
that could be for any reason whatsoever
um the attitude you bring into it the
charisma you come into that day on that
casting the way you look and it could be
anything that person is too skinny that
person's too tall that person is not big
you know anything
and you have to realize that when you
were
casting is they weren't it wasn't
personal it was almost business no you
just don't fit the creator that we want
at the moment that changes when you have
a name that change when you have a brand
because they're buying into your brand
they're buying into your engagement with
your fans that's different but when they
first look at you at face value
and there's different people you know
there's been castings where they're on
the phone they don't say anything to you
you put the book down they go through
two pages and they hand it back to you
now that is a bit demoralizing but hey
you know like i have always made sure i
might probably overcompensate that
because i've been on the other side of
you know casting casting other people
was i'd probably get there for too long
and just chatted and everything else
internet trolls though like someone on
instagram or in the edm's just
you post something and they just
no i'm very full i'm very fortunate that
my fan base which is a very organic fan
base actually on on social
are
massively kind
and positive and that's the way i've
always put social i'm not a big lover of
social media
i've stated it before i see the use of i
see the brilliance of it i also see the
negativity from especially for young
children i've spoken out about that
um
yes does that do things affect yeah of
course you'll probably know this is a
you might see a hundred comments
all positive
and then
101 comment 102 comment is negative and
you'll remember it you'll remember those
two comments so you can't remember the
other hundred that are positive and it's
a really weird thing
so
it's like dealing with people you deal
with the nice ones you don't deal with
the negativity
and
that's what we've tried to do really and
again another sort of social i guess um
not maybe stereotype but sort of
misunderstanding would be that someone
that is you know makes their career out
of modeling someone that's very you know
um attractive um like yourself um surely
they can't have
insecurities surely they realize that
they are you know
surely they can't have self doubts like
us muggles who had gq are yet to call
doesn't everyone have insecurities i
can't believe that you told me there's
not a person that doesn't have
insecurities do you have insecurities
yeah of course i do absolutely
physical insecurities of course they do
had you said something about your if
your nose and your your nose i know my
eyes got any bigger my nose my eyes got
any bigger which they do the only things
that came with like i just look like the
bfg
also i think
something that going back to the sort of
trolling
and
instagram there is this thing about age
now
age is used as a weapon you are so old
look at all your wrinkles it actually
sort of makes me laugh when people say
my god you like
that most people have positive comments
but they can say oh you're getting older
yeah everyone is i've been in this game
for 20 years if you're comparing an
image from 20 years ago i'm not going to
look the same but it's almost like
it's a negative thing
you know it's and that that's
i've noticed that increasing over the
last couple of years is this aged thing
is used as a weapon as if it's a bad
thing does that bother you
no
i always feel i've always been quite an
old man in a young young man's body
anyway
so
should i say mature but um
no you grow old
at the end of the day you grow a little
bit wiser you get a little bit you you
calm down a little bit more
and you you accept
yourself for who you are a little bit
more as well
20s and 30s 30s less but 20s can be
quite tricky for everyone i don't quite
know who you are you're trying to be
trying to find out where you are in the
world you then i think you get a bit
more confidence in your 30 and i that's
where my 30s sort of came from to why
are you trying to be something else or
trying to fit in
and i never fit in i've never fitted in
ever anywhere really particularly well
or felt i haven't particularly fitted in
you're in the fashion industry i've
never felt i fitted in i was telling um
a model the other day actually we were
working with
and we all used to go off to
new york
for this big
casting two weeks try and get the jobs
be with all the big agencies and you
would go and go in a group of probably
about 10 guys and you'd have a list back
in those days you would have a fax
believe it or not you didn't have mobile
phones it was a fact
so you got your fax in the morning you
had all your appointments 9 o'clock 10
o'clock 11 o'clock 12 o'clock all the
way through
everyone used to go down to the subway
or walk and we'll go together and
there's this very pack mentality
and i was never into that pacman tells
you it was quite always a
i'd say a much more sort of individual
sort of loner so i used to look at the
facts and i used to let them go around
the corner and i would vegetate upside
down and do the opposite way so those
nine guys would go to the nine o'clock
and i would go to the six o'clock and i
would just turn up the office and go hi
i'm i know i supposed to be here at nine
o'clock but is
john someone then because yeah yeah he's
here like can i see him
you take the opportunity where you got
imagine going through seeing nine guys
speaking to nine guys looking but by the
third person you're like
they're gonna be bored and you take the
opportunity so i did that all the way
around and that's why i did kind of all
the time it was thinking constantly of
like outside the box of doing something
different
yeah it's amazing how these small things
can create such significant like it's
such a marginal thing can create such a
big gain and most people are obviously
they don't even try and think outside of
the
script and so they end up you know
competing
in a very saturated way for a limited
amount of rewards but one slight
innovation in the process i think can
deliver such an exponential return you
know i hate i hate
powder i hate mixing powder with water i
hate protein powders that you have to
mix with water
up until now and um obviously he'll
sponsor this podcast so i'm tremendously
biased but that's a that's a true story
i've never been able to use the like my
protein powders that you mix with water
because i always think they taste
absolutely awful
up until huel released their brand new
protein flavor the amazing thing about
all of these proteins is there's 20
grams of protein you get all of your
vitamins and nutrients 26 of those and
as huel always is it's nutritionally
complete
and if you are someone that's trying to
go a little bit lower on the calories
it's only 105 calories so when i wake up
in the morning especially i've been
working out a lot lately come downstairs
quickly blend it together in my
nutribullet
drink it's 100 calories and then my next
sort of main meal because i'm a
breakfast skipper will be
at lunchtime highly recommend it um and
i shouldn't say this because i don't
have any
approval to say this but there's some
amazing amazing flavors coming in the
ready to drink range that i've been
lucky enough to try
um and one of those is my new favorite
flavor so stay tuned
in the industry of modeling one thing
that
i think is probably i don't have any
data to support this claim but i think
it's probably rife because of the nature
of the business and what i know about
the subject of mental health and mental
well-being is anxiety
and i i just i've just seen amongst my
friends um
the women that i know that model
high levels of anxiety um for a variety
of reasons um have you ever suffered
with anxiety yourself
at any point in your career
i'm naturally a shy person
but shyness is not anxiety
so i can't say i mean if i probably gave
someone symptoms of stuff i've had or
things that have happened they might say
well that's anxiety
my anxiety
if i still think of
now there's there's a weird thing of
when i hear
the music to the antiques roadshow on a
sunday night i still have anxiety that i
haven't done my homework
and i have to go to school the next day
that's how much i hated
didn't hate i hated school to a certain
point the sixth one was great with my
friends that i still have but that was
the point of
i still have that today when i hear that
music i literally stop and i'm like oh
you know
oh i don't have to go to school tomorrow
what was that about school i mean i was
i didn't fit in at school that was
basically it it wasn't
you know all good friends from that
school but it was just a certain time
before i kind of met those people
um the group of guys cycle and and girls
i used to you know
hang around with and there was bullying
and there was i just didn't fit in that
was all it was but you said you were
bullied in school primary school well
secondary school secondary school yeah
primary was primary was quite fun
enjoyed primary school secondary school
was just something different maybe went
to the wrong school maybe you made the
wrong choices it was me it wasn't i'm
not blaming anyone not blaming anything
it was just
and i was
quite steadfast i'm not fitting in i
didn't fit in particularly well
and i wasn't going to change my way of
fitting into everyone else in what way
didn't you fit in i just i just
a bit like the same night i i'm still
like it so i'm still in the fashion that
example of not being in that group not
not being that pack not doing the same
thing everyone does
exactly the same thing i didn't want to
be in but i saw things differently and
wanted to
do things my way
maybe that's it i mean
maybe it was doing something my way and
and i've always looked at that that goes
on for
that that can go into if you look and go
into styling it's like well no one's
wearing suits oh i'm going to wear suits
and
no one's
you know why don't you do this
it's like you know people still take me
at me because i do not own a pair of
sneakers or trainers
and the people like now everyone that's
all they're wearing
i
have one pair and i go to the gym with
them and i have a running pad but and
everyone sort of looks at you as if but
i love that fact you know it's just me
being a little bit different
but it it can also lead to you know
being a little bit stubborn that you
take that to a little bit far of not
ever relinquishing that you want to be
sort of different like all the time you
want to i don't know why you do it was
that physical but was that bullying
because of physical things they were
they were saying that you were
physically different what was physically
different no the way you know you
thought
maybe it was the way i thought if you
think about that now yeah it's just
because
in
i do find this
still now in the world that everyone
likes to pigeonhole everyone likes to
you are put in a certain category person
and if you don't fit in
then you're strange you're a strange
person why don't you like the same stuff
why don't you wear the same stuff as us
why don't you
think the same way that we think
of course it's now got to say very
polarized when we have different
opinions as they attack each other now
it's like it's either left or right
there's nowhere in the middle and
it was it was i think that element that
i've always just i suppose i've been got
an individual thinker in some ways which
kind of and that might put me in good
stead for the business we're in
um
but yeah the anxiety thing like maybe
it's
a confidence again when i was confident
into going something
i was absolutely fine i just wanted an
opportunity that was always what i want
to be able to
um you know people say why have you not
gone into acting why are you not i'm not
confident if there's anxiety give me a
script to learn and try and put me
in front of a camera and you'll see
that's where i'll probably be anxiety
although i've done that and i achieved
and i quite loved it so it was a scary
side of it but it's not something i'm
naturally
good at isn't that you know people would
people again talking about naivety right
people would never guess that
you would say you weren't confident
and it's almost like because you know
what the conversation had with ben fogle
you were just it was just not what you
would expect based on like stereotypes
one would expect you to be an extrovert
yeah you know super confident some kind
of you know very loud you know
braggadocious boisterous guy but you
appear to be the opposite of that and
especially the point of confidence
yeah i mean
i wouldn't say i've got a lack of
confidence there's a lack of confidence
where i think i know my limitations
maybe i want to but i also like pushing
those limitations to see where i can get
to and seeing what i can achieve and
learn
um
but the confidence i mean
gq awards
we went to two weeks ago
and
you sign up you're
i didn't get an invite but i got the red
i have to sort this out with gq
um
you're on the red carpet i've done it a
million times before there's still dread
filled like i'm filled with dread to
getting on that red carpet and having
the pictures taken it's just not a
natural environment for me and i was
thrilled that there was a
you know a huge long queue because
everyone wanted to be on the red carpet
everyone wanted their picture taken
everyone wanted to be in the papers and
put it on their instagrams and i went
too long i'm not you know i'm going to
swerve that one
so i swerved it and went upstairs and
went into environment where i was much
happier where actually i needed to speak
to a few certain people for a few
certain reasons and went to go and
hunt them down and go and speak to them
what was it about what was the sort of
psychological discomfort you you
feel when you think about going on the
red carpet and doing that because you
described going upstairs to a place
where you were happier so what's the
unhappiness of the red carpet for you
it's just an unnatural environment for
me to be
when you're on set
when you're employed by a brand
to create what is in who is their vision
you're playing a role
like blue i'm a mediterranean guy in
italy and small white speedos it's not
me
it is me but it's it's there's a role
you're playing i know there's actors as
well i've spoken to them about they love
being in character but after those
characters they don't want the limelight
they don't want fame they don't want to
speak to anyone they don't want to do
press junkies they hate the red carpet
exactly the same so when you're on set
you're almost playing someone else
and there's an element as well of
there is
this david gandy and i talk about in a
third person because that's the brand
sometimes i have to talk about that's
the name
so you you
yes you are walking onto a set almost
being something else
not i'm acting any different
but and then there is and and the red
carpet is just not that environment i
can probably
hide behind
a character or hide behind a role or
something when i'm playing on that date
that's me
it's just not something it's strangely
weird training
yeah
my other half steph loves to go out and
love to go to events she gets
you know such a you know a buzz such
gets enthusiasm for it actually like you
know she didn't
and she honestly probably thought that
was me when we first met
i go to an event i'm drained from people
i'm i'm actually naturally a loner i
could you know
we sort of joked with steph when he
first met she would give me a silent
treatment and i was just like steph i'm
going to tell you know i'll win at this
game because
[Music]
i can go off i can go for days not
talking i'm used to it you know i prefer
it yeah i've traveled the you know i
travel the world don't speak to people
for days so um it was always kind of a
joke between us
so um
yeah i'm and then when you're naturally
the complete opposite of being
alone you know i love taking dogs to
work i love walking for hours and then
if i ever ever get sort of proper time
to do it
um with no one around me the exact
opposite of that
is the red carpet
to me
and your life has put you there because
of your success right
and you must get asked to go to red
carpets all the time and events like
that all the time yeah
and there's nothing
[Music]
the actual event
um
i mean again like presenting presenting
an award reading off an auto cue to
present it i mean i it's an honor to do
it i know it's not i know i have to do
it but the whole night
whenever you're presenting is me on that
table
not enjoying that evening because i know
there was one point i've got to go up
there and be in front of everyone and
i've done it a million times now and it
still doesn't get any easier it's very
very strange
but um
you know there you go it's easy to
accept award of course
that's very interesting
again again it's just a real i think for
most people it'd be a real surprise that
um someone who is very out there
visually
yeah no absolutely it makes no sense i
understand that myself i tell people it
makes no sense have you ever spoken to
like a therapist about that or anybody
about probably should do yeah
but no it'd probably be quite
interesting to know why i was and and
actually might help me
overcome some fears when it comes to my
anxiety and it does sound very strange
even when i say it makes no sense
um
and it's probably why
maybe i've
you know there's there's been sort of
striving for
not to be in front of the camera
especially with my own stuff is to be
being ob behind it you know i've been
creative director to quite a few brands
now on advisor and
i've gone and helped just been on so
many shoots so i just said i'll come on
as creative director i don't need to be
paid i just wanna i just love being that
creative element to it
gentleman's journal asked me in the raf
and braylon asked me to direct her raf
film loved it absolutely loved not i
wasn't in front and it was they were
like no no we want you to be in front of
me i was like absolutely not i'll direct
it not cast someone else for it who i
think is perfect for it because i'm not
perfect i'm not good enough for that you
know not good enough but i just don't
suit that role so i need someone else in
it again people look at me and go why
would you not want to put yourself in
that because i wasn't i'm not the right
part for it why
just because the concept i've come up
with in my head is not me
for that role i see someone else
it's it's casting you know it's it's
because you think of the greatest role
you know if you think top gun you think
tom cruise what if they had put someone
else in that would that been the success
it would be probably argue no you got
asked to do 50 shades of grey right i
got
it's a kind of a rumor i got i met the
uh met the author and she said we would
love to send you the script because
everything
and i think it might have got got sent
and i i i admit i'd never read the books
and
yeah
i mean they had they had i mean jamie
didn't you know jamie dornan
an awesome actor you know he was a model
i mean he was one you know he was one of
the biggest models
but he wanted to go into acting and he's
a great actor you know he's a very very
star and i there you know if i ever went
you know i won't go into acting but
looking at that i was like i'm not i
couldn't beat jamie
i couldn't be as good as that
he's very very good and then you look at
the other levels of
sort of uh of other actors and you just
think it's not something i was i could i
could learn i could you know sort of
learn to be quite getting it
but i but i could never even you know
be the best at it i also heard about
hercules 300 you were you're on yeah i
mean it's crosstalk i mean you're always
going to be
asked to do stuff like that just from
the physical element of
the way i look and
you know i'm going to be a part in it
but it wasn't anything i was
i've been you know and that i got my
being bonnet about the instagram in and
where what i wanted to achieve in this
so
there's there's always i said there's a
couple of roles that i would play and i
would drop everything to go and play it
and there's just a couple of stories
that i love i've even which ones
one of them is about winston churchill's
bodyguard
uh walter thompson i even found out who
owns the riots to the to it all
and just the most incredible story and
he was originally from epping in
essex
and
yeah winston churchill asked him to come
back in the second world war he used to
be his bodyguard then he stopped and he
came back
and just the most incredible diary you
mentioned the diaries of being winston
churchill's bodyguard wasn't easy yeah
of course fascinating because of course
winston churchill
that uh i can't whether they called his
episodes the black something or other
which we now probably know as bipolar
yeah you know and walter thompson was
the person that protected everyone or
protected him from everyone seeing that
wow so uh yeah just kept everyone away
from seeing
seeing those episodes that no one would
have realized
speaking of um mental health disorders
then um you've you know you're an
ambassador of a men's mental health
charity
we're working with yeah and we're also
working with calm and um
others for the new brand yeah oh amazing
and um your new brand has a
big sort of theme
around men's wellness
and um what does it what i guess the
question is why why did that matter to
you
and this is also why i asked the
question around anxiety because
for you to make it a kind of mental
well-being let's say a central part and
mental wellness are essential part of
your brand
and your mission
one would assume that you've had an
experience with it close to home because
i think
that's one way that people typically
generate a ton of empathy towards the
subject matter is feeling it feeling the
pain of it whether within themselves
within loved ones so what was it for you
that made you care so much about that
i've never suffered from depression
as when i'm very fortunate from as badly
as other people
have and i've witnessed it because i've
dated people
that were then diagnosed with bipolar
and i've seen the extremities of
mental
you know
mental health um
me myself
and i admit it's it's not happened for a
while would go into dark periods
knowing i would snap out of it
eventually
but they were dark but nothing would
nothing would suffice nothing would
cheer you up just
quite in a dark place wanting to be on
my own just not around anyone
wasn't triggered by anything
but just one day i just knew i'd wake up
and it was gone
just a chemical a chemical reaction in
your brains basically
what what it is
and yeah so i've i do understand and i
can spot it in other people as well what
were the symptoms of it for you those
dark periods
the symptoms as a as i said was was just
nothing would make you
you you couldn't snap out of it was
nothing could make you happy or cheerful
you
know you didn't like anyone you didn't
want to be around anyone
um
it's hard to
the feelings are hard to explain
and it was it never got to any point of
seriousness i mean i've seen people
bipolar that will be in a room
for hours on end for days on end
watching the same tv series because that
their safety is watching that tv series
and makes them a little bit happy you
know because of just that safety for
some reason so i've seen i've seen
the real dark side of it and
i've also
from me
dating someone like that
of how hard it is to deal with it
because you always want to try and make
that person better
and you can't in in many many ways
it's you can talk and you have to be you
know it's about just being patient
and listening to people
and trying to get them you know help
professional help there is an element we
you know
i i can only talk about certain around
the point and then it comes to an expert
help that that they have to talk and
that's what calm does you know it's it's
it's allowing people to talk to people
um and there are people that are far
better
people need to listen to people that's
that's the point of it i think there's a
lot of people who
even if
they are talking to people they're not
listening
fortunately
it's never been that bad but i do
understand it do you sleep well no i
heard you hadn't slept well for almost
two decades no never slept well i didn't
sleep when i was a child
but i did was the other way around went
to bed early got ups you know went to
bed you go to bed early and then my
parents just left me being the end i
think they were just so sick of trying
to get me to go to bed because i just
didn't sleep
and i would be doing my homework at
midnight one o'clock in the morning
i still work now i was up till two
o'clock in the morning working last
night and that's another thing when
people go it's grafting or hard work
most people seem a lot of people are
sitting down that half past eight nine
o'clock in front of a tv race go to bed
half past eight i'm going to the gym get
back up online do the shopping on the
way home cook myself some dinner go it
doesn't stop in between is
working on the phone
carrying on you know they'll you know
pop us 10 or open the laptop and get
them with some more work
if you're always grafting as you call it
and it's and you said it doesn't stop
how does one
become happy if they're always striving
if they're always in the future or
did stop jim pandemic
you so you sorry it did stop during the
power during lockdown right yeah you
couldn't my my
behalf the business is my business the
modelling is traveling pretty much at
the end of the day you have to be in
locations
yeah it made you happy when it all
stopped
to financial
you know it affected me financially yeah
and we'd already been infected quite
heavily in this industry by
um you know say the brexit isn't it
the blame of brexit now
it was the uncertainty of brexit so a
lot of brands were not spending money
not marketing money not having not
having budgets
not working with the uk all this stuff
different things also on certain brands
with social media
now of
old school campaigns versus digital
which still hasn't quite fizzled out yet
they don't brands don't quite know where
they are within the marketing world on
how to how to market to people how to
target people so
it's been affected by it
and
you know that all kind of brexit
got signed january whole different world
it was sort of that december january of
what 2020. i was off to milan i was then
going to spain i was then going to
greece i was then going to new york i
was saying back to well i had the
schedule like it used to be going off
out to russia and i've been to russia
was really excited about going to russia
for the first time
in the pandemic yet
everything got cancelled
and you're saying you were happier
during the pandemic probably shouldn't
have been it's not unfortunate i'm very
very fortunate and the fact is that yes
it affected
me financially
but it slowed you down i've invested
well and i've you know it
there's reserves to yeah yeah point this
out but um nice card collection yeah
exactly that's an expensive thing to be
honest um
there's a time probably the only time i
actually probably truly switch off and
there's a week between christmas and new
year
and that's when everyone i mean everyone
virtually everyone
is
not doing anything during that week yeah
and that's a week where
i probably switch off the most
and we always sort of go away a week
later after that because because it
takes time for people to get back and
i suppose there's it's not fear of
missing out it's fear of other people
working and i'm not working i should
always be working and during the
pandemic no one was working how can you
how can how can one be happy with with
their brain saying those things that
that kind of constant nagging to be
doing something or doing more or to be
striving how can that sounds like the
the thief of happiness to me the thief
of happiness that's a good i should be a
book
um probably is
listen i haven't got the answers to that
would you consider yourself to be a
happy person
a positive person
why did you avoid the word happiness i
don't know
completely honest that's something you'd
probably have to ask her
ask a psychologist i don't know happy
person
i'm a positive person and i suppose i am
a happy person in many ways
yes that's right but i so it's just a
definition of what's positive what's
happening is it all the same thing
so in many ways in what ways do you
think you might not be a happy person
again good question i i mean
i am
i'm happy
[Music]
i put myself listen when
i'm in control of what i do now
that's why i always wanted it
anybody my control fair i don't know
the hard work that's
where we've got to has allowed me now to
to be in complete control of what my
destiny of what i want to do
if i want to renovating interiors huge
passion love doing it looks like a
nightmare hard work for other people but
i strive on it
renovating classic cars the same thing
as i said to you earlier
you're halfway through you think why am
i doing this why didn't i just buy a new
car or you know a new
bui the
accomplishment is worth it to me
you know that sense of achievement
that's what i'm striving for
does it ever feel as good when you get
there
yeah it does not for that long but it
does
i can take this
couple of days
yeah it's it's the same feeling as
you know when we if we're going to shoot
light blue or something else and
you have to work hard
you know in the gym to get i'm always in
pretty decent shape but that's
hard work to get in that shape and it's
getting harder the older i get
and
you dedicate a lot and you sacrifice a
lot to
look like that
and then there is that point of we've
shot it we've seen through the pitch it
looks incredible you've achieved it and
there is this
evening
of enjoying that
it's then on to the next thing you know
it's what are we working on not next but
you know one of the other projects that
i'm working on at the time
do you have you found that in your
career
dark episodes where you're where you
feel down sometimes follow high episodes
because there's this really fascinating
thing that i was reading about about
gold medal depression where up to 80 of
um olympians regardless of outcome
regardless of whether they win or they
don't come back from the olympics after
training all of that excruciating effort
and they come back and 80 percent of
them report sort of depressive symptoms
i've read that i don't know where i was
i don't know where i've read that i've
read the same thing and i could actually
resonate with that in in many ways
sometimes actually achieving what what
you want is
a bit it's sometimes the journey is the
exciting bit
which is a weird thing to say
it's we are on this journey of well
where david ghani the brand at the
moment and it is
so much hard work
um tell me about that
that whole inspiration the journey why
why the brand yeah
because it was what i've wanted to
achieve for so long
is have that to me to have your own
brand and i didn't know what it was
going to be
i am a brand you know that's i say that
and it makes me sound like a bit of a
dick no but you are but it is a brand
and that's where people have to realize
you know when i say only sometimes
that that's and then
i would probably say it's 10 years i've
thought yes that's where one day i'd
like to not saying i'm always going to
achieve it but yes from the creative
side to being in control of that brand
i'm always in control from
by other brands even if i'm
collaborating with a brand there is
still an element of control that
that brand has
and
i always thought yeah to be in complete
control complete creative control and
that's a risk i never wanted people to
think because i have a name because i've
been in the fashion industry for so long
i could start a brand now people do now
you know they use social media
one of the one of those elements is you
can start something you can sell it
immediately you've got
fans followers buyers
it's made the marketplace a very
different place so i went back to really
what i did for modeling observation
putting myself in
the situation where i could learn and
that was m s
the collaboration with m s we saw the
david gandy loungewear no one was doing
loungewear this was
what are we talking about the concept
it was about six seven seven and a half
years ago seven years ago lounge lounge
where it wasn't a big concept it wasn't
it wasn't something that people thought
about um and of course we did sleepwear
and t-shirts and everything else but it
was loungewear that really took off and
became the third biggest lounge in the
country and was successful
and it had
you know
60 to me in that brand as in what i
wanted to achieve on that brand but of
course you couldn't get that last 40
because that was mns and i knew where i
wanted to go i knew what needed to be
done
but i couldn't
push it any further than i sort of could
so that ended and then the pandemic
hit and and locked down
and one of my greatest friends charlie t
who has listened to me
talk far too long about wanting to start
my own thing and
he started his own branding
agency
to do exactly what i wanted
and he said well listen i've started
this now you can be our first client but
we're not talking about this anymore
we've got the time i've you know as my
best friend who knows i'm never really
around it's i've got you here
we work together i've gone i've got you
in the country we've got time let's
start it what's your long-term vision
then for
well where
what's that what's the term what's it
gonna become five ten years from now
i'd never really tell people where i've
got in my head where something is going
hopefully going to be and there are
small steps just you know to where we
haven't even you know properly launched
yeah yeah the first ship and goes out on
22nd of october um
but we wanted to do something different
with well where we wanted to
to the essence of me it was
understanding and we're calling it sort
of well we're well-being
why clothing why does some clothing make
you feel positive and confident
why do some not
and we looked at
we the studies done by amsterdam
university and i think it was a
scientific you know element of
if we put
students in comfortable confident
clothing they're confident that's
comfortable and soft their results are
better than other people who are in
uncomfortable clothing and they don't
feel as confident at all that's going in
the same with business
it was now why the banks the big banks
are saying you don't have to wear suits
anymore because actually a lot of people
are more positive they're a lot more
open to work with they're a lot calmer
it's oxytonin it's the same thing as
feeling
the ridiculously you know soft pillow or
puppy that softness that soft jumper
can't you know that that thing you hold
on to is oxitone it's released into your
brain it's a positive positive move and
that's what we wanted to do with and we
looked into this and
you know there was a side to me that was
fascinated by the element of it but i've
always wondered why do i
why do i hold on to that pair of jeans
until
my ass is falling out the end of it and
i would try and find that pair again
when i can't find that pair
and
why am i wearing those sweatshirts
because
well it was
one for comfort and that is an element
of lots of things in the materials
the breathability the style you still
gotta look stylish in it it makes you
feel confident the fit
that's why at the end of the day
that's why it was never to me about
being trendy it was being confident and
so many guys said to me
what do i do what do i wear here what
are you confident in
and then we've thought about every
element
of the sweatshirts and the hoodies and
the t-shirts of comfort level of style
of fit of quality of well-wear breathe
well wear care we've
put these elements into um
they're washed into the clothing that is
aloe vera so pyjamas are moisturizing
you whilst your sleep anti-inflammatory
we've got well-wear breathe and you know
sort of anti-bacterial elements of it
which is
another element of
we're looking at fast fashion
fast fashion can be an addiction and
people don't realize this addiction
that you get a buzz from shopping but
actually you can be
hugely affected knowing the impact of
fast fashion on the environment actually
when that clothing lasts a week
two weeks i was exaggerating it last you
know but it can do some some people wear
it once and chuck it away yeah it's
actually it can negatively impact you
okay so there's a new
segment to this podcast we do
what we do is we ask our previous guest
to leave a question for our next guest
and um i've not read this question yet
but i've just read it then as i said
this um so i'm going to ask you this
question asked by someone that was sat
in this the chair before you okay
they told me to ask you
what do you promise to do
to make our world a better place
okay can i have an easier question
let me hit this right yeah yeah two
weeks before yeah
just uh yeah let's let's take it back to
hopefully
promise to do um
there's a number of things i do for
number charities but we won't talk about
that and they're not promises but i
suppose the promises from well where to
make people smile yeah
to bring to bring back some
the positivity that i think is needed
somewhere and i think we're with in this
polarized world that we are in
is just to
say [ __ ] it we're just going to make
people smile
and and and have a laugh with everything
that we do and and i think you uh you
can't put a magic value on that so
that's what i promised to try and do
over the years of well we're perfect
amazing thank you so much and you're
gonna have to write in the book now as
well okay a question for someone else
but listen david thank you so much for
your time it's such an incredibly
inspiring and twisting story of yours
and to see where you are now and taking
on this this next adventure in business
i find incredibly exciting the
entrepreneur me is fascinated by by that
and i understand the challenge of that
so
yeah well thank you for having me
i wish i could have yeah you put out
some good some good questions i probably
might need to no i could answer that's
what i think i want to do i just always
want to pry but i pry because i'm
curious and because i'm like fascinated
by those topics myself it's like there's
nothing written down here that's telling
me to speak on those terms but yeah it's
so fascinating and you also your level
of self-awareness i think is just really
inspiring for a lot of people
i i think it's something it's just
there's a therapeutic thing to
talking of course i mean men don't do it
we're useless um
that's mental health they wanted to know
is people asking you talking yeah that's
what i'm saying a lot of people don't
actually listen yeah um a lot of talking
about yourself a lot of people talking
about themselves at the moment so
there's a therapeutic side to this yeah
exactly for me as well you know that's
what that's actually how it started it
was like it was like therapy for me
because i was doing on my own going
through my diary and just you know but
um it's it's honestly amazing and thank
you so much for giving us that story
because it's um such an inspiring one
thank you thank you
quick one as you probably know by now
i'm trying to make my life a little bit
more sustainable and i consider myself
to be on a bit of a sustainability
journey in the same way that i'm on a
health journey and it's a privilege to
be able to share that with all of you
and you you'll know if you've listened
to the last podcast that i traded in my
range over sport in for an electric
bicycle which is now my only vehicle and
next year hopefully i'll have my
electric car too if tesla hurry up with
a cyber truck and that's where my energy
comes into my life and my sort of
sustainability journey it makes your
life if you are on that sustainability
journey 10 times easier this is one of
their if you can't see this i'm holding
in my hand if you're listening on
spotify or apple this is one of their
renewable energy products if you're
watching on youtube you'll you'll see
this this is called the harvey it's this
very clever little device that allows
the zappy and the eddy which i've talked
about before on this podcast to be
installed into your home without hard
wiring or without batteries or without
those um god-awful transformers that a
lot of people have in their house it's
basically a tiny device that's going to
save you both time and money and for
someone like me who doesn't have loads
of time on our hands it's a real life
saver if you're looking to make a
conscious switch and you need a quick
fix that's going to save you a load of
time then head over to myenergy.com to
see this product and many many more
[Music]
[Music]
you